alors écoutez comment faut-il s'y
prendre stéphane parce que c'est une
question que se posent de nombreux
adolescents qui débute
oui comment faut-il s'y prendre pour
trouver une compagne au premier jour du
printemps
j'espère que quand faut-il s'y prendre
il ya des spécialistes
oui et cette semaine j'ai découvert un
spécialiste de ce que l'on appelle la
drague un garçon un professionnel à
prendre certains dragueur professionnel
et j'ai également découvert une jeune
femme qui elle ne supporte pas les
dragueurs et qui a fait un livre à ce
sujet voilà c'est tout vous allez
pouvoir suivre lauriad et il ya il faut
en prendre et en laisser
à vous de juger vous savez si vous dites
ça à propos de la drague il faut en
prendre et en laisser écouter c'est une
enquête sur la drague les hameçons pour
les femmes sont contre pas toujours
ils sont tous prêts l'époque où les
garçons se montre un peu plus
entreprenants vis-à-vis des filles bref
c'est l'époque de la draille ce jeune
homme s'appelle roland gaillac
il a 26 ans et se proclame modestement
droit et dragueur il écrit en ce moment
un livre sur les techniques pour draguer
vous allez pouvoir constater que c'est
un remarquable théoricienne ya deux
sortes de dragueur ça se décomposant le
dragueur tout terrain celui qui drague
n'importe où n'importe quoi n'importe
comment n'importe quel temps par
n'importe quel temps qui est en quelque
sorte un bestial investir ailleurs tout
terrain à l'arrière soute à voile et
puis il ya le psychologue qui lui agir
aux finesses de l'artiste quant à cette
jeune femme
eh bien elle c'est aurélie à brillac 28
ans c'est tout le contraire
elle ne supporte pas valeur vraiment pas
les dragueurs et elle vient d'écrire un
livre qui s'appelle de la drague où ils
en prennent vraiment pour leur grade
alors comment procède le dragueur tout
terrain déjà pendant la première
catégorie je dois dire tout terrain il
se cantonne dans les clichés en général
il dresse dans la rue il va prendre 9
claque la dixième fois ça va marcher à
il aborde avec les phrases stéréotype du
type vous habiter chez vos parents c'est
à vous c'est bozella et caetera et
continue doit un peu plus malin il va
utiliser un calembour du type que se
passe-t-il magna qui fait avant que thil
valda par exemple je sais pas c'était le
val d'adour
c'est le genre de chose qui fait rire
souvent nous on est en se libère enfin
le même boulot que les armées puis il
continua de raconter la même connerie
d'un genre vous habiter chez vos parents
vous avez de beaux yeux
si tu as vu tout ça bien souvent une
fille dans la rue va vous dire non et la
même fille le même le soir même mais
dans des circonstances différentes
non ce sera très bien le plus
insupportable c'est qu'il prend à la
fille au départ pour une
une sous développés mental le premier
passé l'abordage cinq édifices
l'abordage alors là c'est d'ailleurs il
faut qu'elles répondent par tous les
moyens
bon il ya un truc qu'il ya un truc par
exemple qui est tout bête mais qui est
marrant efficace qui est efficace on
peut en france en tout cas en france
parce qu'il ya des bons et des
différences en fonction des pays en
france c'est d'avancer la parole à une
fille en anglais par exemple
just can't buy me rends toi tu
recherches
concert souvenir la vérité là tels que
cherchez vous voyez là pour l'invité à
boire un verre quand rapidement nombre
assez rapidement à commencer par exemple
quand un type vous dit dans l'intention
de draguer on va prendre un verre ça
veut dire on va coucher ensemble
alors ça c'est la technique tout terrain
où l'on risque de prendre des baffes
donc alors reprendre sur l'impro
systématiquement si on prend neuf fois
sur dix des baffes 9 fois sur 10 mais la
dixième fois où l'on nous la deuxième ou
la troisième samar autres techniques
subtiles utilisé par roland gaillac la
pièce de monnaie ont fait croire à la
personne qu'on veut draguer qu'elle a
fait tomber une pièce avait perdu très
bien distincts
comment savoir vous et c'est pas bête et
du coup je me suis dit que je pourrais
peut-être essayer alors pour ce il faut
évidemment se cacher et ne pas attirer
l'attention
on s'est raté
elles m'ont vu
oh là là vous avez fait tomber tout ça
les faire tomber
effet
vous avez fait tomber des
mais pas boire un verre mais va boire un
verre c'est ton bde
j'ai vu que c'était l'élément merci
ça c'est la fille elle marche parle bon
alors offert ont fait une grande voix là
voilà le c à vous la croisez l'a61 point
de croisement à vous faites un détour
par là pour arrivé par derrière et là
vous marcher à côté c'est la meilleure
méthode parallèle et si elle fait
demi-tour ces essais si elle essaye de
vous soumets seahawk si vous prenez le
cas par exemple on sait toujours là
imaginons qu'elle se met à marcher en
zigzag pour vous semez où vous êtes à
côté ici voilà qu'est ce que vous faites
dans ces cas là il faut marcher ainsi
que ça aussi demandé alors écoutez vous
savez bien cinq minutes écouter quand
vraiment un petit peu trop emmerdant je
lui dis alors fait le tapa mon pauvre
vieux et en général c'est radical parce
que tipi ça cool c'est vrai d'ailleurs
un type dans la rue qui vous emmerde
comme ça au fond il fait la retape quoi
il fait exactement et se prostitue
ils s'offrent ils se proposent et en
général ça les mecs tellement qu'ils
arrêtent la japonaise vous dira toujours
non enfin presque et surtout pas se
laisser décourager parce que toujours
non jusqu'au dernier moment en ligne
comment ni non japonais on dit mais ce
n'est pas ce que vous venez boire un
verre avec moi
est ce que vous venez boire un verre
avec moi
mais ni madame à dîner mais disons que
celui qui applique fabien ses méthodes
il arrive à quel volume annuel à peu
près à nu un type normal un type normal
peut arriver même à une par semaine sauf
une cinquantaine par an tu sais sa
sirène sahraouis c'est raisonnable c'est
raisonnable qu'elle aura encore à leurs
records le record shop à trois points
jours oui pour se vanter comme ça le
dragueur il n'est pas sûr de sa virilité
parce qu'un homme qui est vraiment
séduit sans vraiment sûr de lui vraiment
bien dans sa peau il n'a pas besoin de
s'inventer comme ça plein de succès et
de parents dit devant les copains pas
que la meilleure en fait c'est une
question de goût il ya des fanatiques de
la japonaise n'est fait rage à la
chinoise la chinoise il ya des
fanatiques de la chinoise et la chinoise
hong kong à l'anglais on en trouve là ah
oui on en trouve qu'il faut avant tout
quand on quand on veut draguer c'est
respecter la femme vous n'êtes pas
considérer la femme comme un objet ou
comme une marchandise
surtout le vide est en tout cas excusez
moi si je vous dis c'est naturel non ne
partez pas garder ça semble avoir été
témoin et quoi je trouve cet aspect
souriez ou moi s'il vous plaît
pourquoi pas l'air sympathique
tu as l'air gentil d'ailleurs même type
[Musique]